hello everyone hi my name is Yoon Jin
I'm a co-founder of a startup called a
life site in Silicon Valley and I am
very honored to be you know standing
here and give a lecture and today I'm
going to cover the story about
entrepreneurship between South Korea and
Asia and between Asia and Silicon Valley
and my personal experience being on an
entrepreneur and also as an investor so
what is this globe right first when I
was really little when I was young I
always had this idea that I wanted to be
a global person my mom bought me a glove
and I was looking at all the continents
in the glove and of thinking I live in
this tiny country but what's out there
so my story everything started from this
curiosity that what's the world out
there and I started to execute on my
dream so first execution was learning
English and second was I actually asked
my parents that when I was 4 13 that I
want to go u.s. by myself and learn
about culture and learn about the
diversity so my father who works at
government he's a military man and he
found a government program from us and I
took the test I got septic so I went
high school in Evanston Illinois for
sophomore and junior year and I learned
that there are more people out there who
have different culture different values
but we can find a way to coordinate
because when I first moved there and
studied at high school I was the only
Korean and actually I got bullied
because I didn't speak English as much
as they do and also I wore differently I
speak differently right
so they just started to bully me and I
was trying to figure out why they see
the difference and they see distance on
me and and I started to understand they
are just different and if I want to get
to know them I should understand their
difference like their their culture what
they eat how they hang out so I started
to adapt the culture that I found out
myself that I can survive here so all
that you know my journey started from my
high school year that I was confident
that I can come here and do anything
after high school year after college
year I've done a lot of work besides TV
I've done a lot of industry works
fashion oil business and I was involved
with so many other government
ambassadors work after I became Miss
Korea son so I was crowned to be 2010
with Korea Tom I was titled
and I was able to travel all around the
world and was able to connect with all
the people including politicians
business people and like TV
entertainment people all different types
of people and the reason I went to
pageant is actually when I was working
as interns at Korea times I was
interviewing a lot of Korean American
and I realized that pageant can be
another platform to execute and let
people know about Korea and at the time
a lot of people actually talked about
honey Lee and who was fourth place of
the Miss Universe and I realized people
pay attention even though she was you
know she was just Miss Korea maybe but
she was actually representing to crush
her that people pay attention to her
through her beauty that I wanted to use
the Miss Korea platform to go global and
I shared my vision and my
dream with the judges and even though I
was oldest Miss Korea you know I was
actually when I actually run went for
the pageant a lot of judges like you are
way too over your age for to go in a
pageant because most girls who run for a
pageant there at 19 when I was 24 I
already had a working experience and
they really how like how did you even
come up with the idea you can run for
pageant when you're 24 then and I told
judges that but I have a different
vision they might come here to show the
beauty but I want to use this platform
to let people know about Korea and I was
right and through the Miss Korea
experience I was able to connect all
different types of people around the
world China US Japan everywhere and then
one day I got a phone call and it was
from David Lee who was my former partner
at case startup which was first startup
accelerator in Korea and he sent me a
random email and random call all of a
sudden and the first thing I answer to
him was like how did you even find me
and why do you want to work with me and
I wasn't sure how he would you know he
even came up with the idea that you know
he wanted to work with me when while I
was working at TV station I had my own
show at the time I was having a
glamorous time on my life and when he
asked me I I was like okay so what do
they going to what what do they do and
what are their mission and K startups
mission was to help clean entrepreneurs
make their business grow and go global
which aligns with my own mission and my
vision of my life so when I talk to my
partners KJ and David Lee
we started the first startup accelerator
in Korea it was the first time in Korea
that we had no idea how you know really
properly run the accelerator so first
thing we started was we brought
entrepreneurs in Silicon Valley and
there were young entrepreneurs MIT
graduated funded by Sequoia Capital and
all just like really famous angel
investor including David that they were
sharing their story how it was difficult
for them to start the company from the
garage and then you know every time they
want to focus on product but they have
to do the fundraising at the same time
that you know they want to share the
story to Korean startup that Korean
startup can come to us and start their
business and I happen to get to really
close to my mentor pool and we became
really close friends that whenever I had
doubt about myself about being tech
world when I'm not engineer they were
encouraging me that yunjin you'll be the
next Jessica Livington who is the YC
partner Paul Grimm's wife that don't
worry because your talent is actually
will help a lot of Korean entrepreneurs
to go global
so K startup we invested 40k and we were
the first Asian Google partner in Asia
that I was exposed to a lot of VCS and
business people in Silicon Valley
including professor - sure
and I helped and manage all the sporty
startups I was I had no weekend you know
I was literally chatting with all the
founders including designer and
engineers we came up with the idea with
the product and everything so I learned
like a dog dog ears you know I was
participating there
early stage of their startup and I was
really fascinated and I met and brought
so many good Silicon Valley
entrepreneurs including my current
co-founder Chris wah and brought them to
Korea to mentor my startup staff what is
the core difference between Silicon
Valley and Korea and we did actually get
a pretty good track record as case
startup so 70 to 80 percent of our
portfolio we got additional funding
which is really hard when you look at
the statistics so this is a statistics
from 2016 and if you look at this graph
you see there's a abundant money towards
the seed round and procede realm it's
because when we first started the
company and accelerator 2013 was the
peak time Vic the govern Korean
government wanted to boost the ecosystem
of startup that they start putting
$1,000,000 every year to boost ecosystem
and so we had a lot of you know money
towards the seed round but their
difficulty and the limitation that I
actually faced helping Korean
entrepreneur was actually after the
acceleration time so if you look at this
from Series A to exit there's you know
dramatically drop the funding so which
means like there is a limit of ecosystem
for Series A funding round and what's
worse about Korean actually ecosystem
was there's no exit it's it's almost
zero and it really was actually hard for
me even I was not an entrepreneur I was
helping them because they look for you
know their growth they want to be
next job they want to be next Samsung
but they also know that there's a
limitation that they can grow or they
can sell the company and so if you look
at this this is a number of start-up in
2015 that after two to three years
number of startup dramatically drop they
can't sustain their business because
they cannot get funded and also because
of these reasons so and I analyzed this
and the first biggest obstacle for
Korean startup to grow was the market
opportunity or in market
Marcus ice that they're facing maybe the
market site itself is you know big
enough because coupon is now more than
five million dollar company there's a
yellow mobile there's Heather I mean
joke there are a couple of billion I
mean five of them like as a billion
dollar unicorn company but the thing is
if they're not the first leader out the
market and they're not the first they're
not Samsung or they're not LG then
there's no acquisition where there's no
exit that most of them there's they just
die I actually when I was working at the
K startup I was interviewing and
actually it just went to aldo you know
successful founders that ask help what's
what is your secret source to be
successful as a Korean startup and one
of them was the Heather I mean joke
which is a first delivery service and
now as a Unicron company that Kim
bulging depe me actually told me that
the reason he was able to dominate the
market was he was the first so if you're
the second then you have to spend tons
of money to acquire users and also it's
almost impossible to compete with the
market leader that it's I would actually
not
encourage other startups to go into the
same industry when there's a market
leader and dominate the market that's
what he said
so I was devastated to hear that but at
the same time it kind of gives me hope
and then also encouragement that K
startup is helping them to not just
focus on Korean market but to go global
so which means you know all this lack of
you know market opportunity or lack of
exit Korean startup still have an
opportunity to go big through global
markets also there was a challenge for a
lot of startups after seed round after
one or two years a lot of them they they
doubt about themselves because there's a
you know lack of funding and also the
families and friends they are not really
supported in terms of culture and Korea
people we like brand we like names we
like Samsung realise LG I am a doctor
I work at Samsung that's actually kind
of like the status of who you are which
is not always the true but like you know
it's changing definitely but it has been
because our economy from Korean War were
Korean were we dramatically grew from
all those companies effort like
Hyundai's and Samsung and they hired
smart people and then we work days and
nights to you know grill are coming and
we became one of the top GDP countries
that people fear to start the startup
and people fear to sustain their
business when there's you know there's
there's more actually percentage to you
know fail
I mean it's the same thing in Silicon
Valley but it's at least a Silicon
Valley there's like a lot of acquisition
like Google acquire and Facebook
acquired you hear all those stories but
Korea is not so I had to encourage
Korean startups my entrepreneurs
especially when they get Marian child
they really fear they couldn't sleep and
every time they fund rate they just have
nervous attack I won't have to make sure
that what they're following is very
spent you know that the following to
dream is very special and and you're not
the only person who's going through so
one of the thing I was actually really
focusing was I make the startups case of
startups as a family that they support
each other the founder to pull you're
not the only one who's going through
this let me help you with my engineer
let me help you with my designer that
was a focus that I had to do when I was
running the accelerator and actually it
worked because for example there is a
company called a missile and they were
the third Korean startup who got
accepted by YC recently and the miso
actually started from the company called
attention it was a dating application
and they failed because there was
already you know dominant market leader
as a dating application so they fail but
they merge with another startup in case
startups and then they recreate a really
good engineering team and really good
team and they create a team called miso
and they apply for YC and they got
accepted and they got funded and they're
you know
generating a lot of revenue right now so
that was the thing I I I was learning
through case startup so and also I
brought a lot of startups to Silicon
Valley to get investment and I also
taught them how to pitch in front of
investors especially in English
and because Prada matters but product is
not the one that only matters like you
need to know how to sell it to customer
to investors so I actually happen to
know how to speak in front of public
hopefully I'm doing well
right now that I actually you know tutor
my entrepreneurs every Friday and
luckily most of them they won all the
competition and they got funded or they
got grants and I you know research and
went everywhere in the world like
Singapore Hong Kong u.s. New York
Silicon Valley to research what's out
there so and I made a partnership sort
of like a partnership with the Y
Combinator for the first time that they
were able to the startups from Korea
they were able to get mentor from people
like Michael Seibel that you see on the
picture he sold twitch for $1,000,000 to
Yahoo that you know the Korean startup
they they can get inspired and they can
seed what's different with Silicon
Valley and you know Asia and Korean
market but it was not good enough you
know bring all those people and giving
some recipes of you know or sorcery of
the success it was not good enough for
me to you know understand everything
help those entrepreneurs and I shared
this hunger with my current co-founder
Chris Wong was sitting over there and
initially we were actually going to
start our own fund and help those Korean
entrepreneur and bring to us because he
has Network I know the market in Asia I
have a network so we were very confident
that we could help those people that we
were actually going to start the fund
but then one day it's another one phone
call yes that he called me and eugen I'm
sending you a pitch deck and after what
is it
and it was about life sight so life
sight what we do is a dis little safety
deposit box we manage and store all the
life important documents and information
in your life and then easily share with
your family members advise your anyone
you trust I'm pretty sure all the
audience here they have their own
personal story how to handle how
difficult it is to actually share all
the you know your medical information or
your you know even grandma's recipe with
your family member who live far from
from from here like you know like maybe
from East Coast or other country and
when I saw this idea it just hit me like
okay this is something that I'm
personally able to relate to and it was
related to security which I always want
to learn and this is going to be us
company that if I know how to execute
you know all this high technology
including cloud security you know and I
knew that this company this idea is not
just focused on the US and also it will
it will go to global to anywhere there's
especially disaster like Indonesia or
Japan that this was perfect platform for
me to go another step to go global
so I told Chris that you know what I'll
do it so I left everything I had built
and family member everything and then
start my own company in our own living
room my arriving room yes it was very
difficult
now it was in here yes so I came here by
myself and we start our own company and
built all the IKEA furnitures I did not
get paid and I was the only foreign
founder all my teams are you know
non-korean I thought I was pretty good
at adapting to culture and you know my
English is not too bad that I thought it
would have been you know not too
difficult but I made a mistake it was
very difficult and my team also had to
go through some of the difference that I
have as personality-wise or cultural
eyes they sometimes you know call me
that told me that I do que rage so I I'm
so used to it everything you know doing
fast assess that my team member they
sometimes drag the conference like you
know or meeting a lot and it kind of
frustrated I yell at them and they just
say oh you're drink a rage so all those
things were learning journey and now we
have three products we have consumer
product and enterprise software and a
price product that we're generating
revenue and we raise five million
dollars for seed round and we're raising
I think I don't know I can say there
yeah we just raised three million
dollars almost yeah this and a lot of
people ask me how did you do it as a
Korean entrepreneur because more than I
think 99% of the Korean entrepreneur who
start the company here they fail most of
them unless they are korean-american or
they know culture very well but my power
was my team
so I have very diverse team with
different age different race different
background I have more team actually I
have 20 employees right now we have
Indian people
we have Caucasian we have Chinese I'm
the only Korean and I'm the only
actually actually I became there's a
second one who actually moved from India
so I'm no longer only foreigner in our
company but for all the journey lesson
that I had from my startup and and try
to figure out why Korean startup were
not able to execute well in the United
States was actually the cooperation in
teamwork I did not know until I came
here that how important it is actually
because Korea is very hierarchy you know
society it is good and bad because we
execute very fast because the order it
comes from up from down that you have to
you do your work no matter what then you
know maybe there's no time for
creativity but you use you still do your
work that there's result but including
my company's local value companies are
usually flat flat culture so even though
I'm a co-founder and I have my partner
co-founder SEO we never have any issue
with oh you just have to follow what I
said we discuss and when we discuss and
when we respect the difference we
actually come up with the very unique
and special idea that all led to our
business and that all led to our product
for example there is a function call I
mean there's a product called A+ which
which is focusing on the family members
to share all this information
and we did have that idea but I when I
went back to Korea I was back and forth
for a while and I was working on some of
the paper with my visa lawyer
immigration process that I had to
exchange really crucial document with my
lawyer when I was in Korea and there was
no secure tool to share and she didn't
know how to set up the safe secure mail
software and so she I she was like Yoon
Jin can you just send me all the
passport all your credential through
email which is like dangerous and as
much I learn about security oh you know
what I can't give you you know sir email
so why don't you just come to my life
site and when I came back to my team and
share my experience that there's got to
be a lot of families out there that day
when they travel and when they are
outside of the US or you know they have
to find a way to share all this
important information and document
easily and safely so I share that
experience and my team respected that
and it turned out to be product and then
actually people see the value the most
because it came from the personal you
know experience and and I'm very
thankful that they actually value my
experience and even though I was you
know not engineering background I'm not
an engineer who code right but they
still respect my opinion as a business
person as a co-founder that I was able
to you know even charge of some of the
features in Prague and you know and I
was very happy to see my idea turning
into product and I was able to sell it
so I really do believe that the power of
Silicon Valley is all cooperation
cooperation between team member
cooperation between entrepreneur and VC
or any other organization like
government organization it's all
cooperation and people matter
people are the one who's going to give
you opportunity and people are going to
be the one that who's going to execute
your dream York you cannot do it by
yourself but when I look at a lot of
Korean starters who come to Silicon
Valley and try to get the advice from me
I see the limitation this is my personal
opinion but first is they're not ready
to accept the new culture if you are in
Rome you got to follow the Rome's
you know rule right but we Koreans we've
been invaded by so many countries over
the time that we're very much very
protected that we're not open to accept
other culture that when they do a
business especially globally it became a
huge obstacle because when you run your
business in a different country you need
to know the regulations you need to know
how people think you need to know the
culture to approach customer right but
we stick with our own Korean stigma that
we run our company in a Korean way and
only talking to Korean people that you
don't really get funded funding and also
you don't attract customer who are not
Korean so that was one of the thing I
realized that it's it's a biggest hurdle
and actually biggest challenge and
difficulty of Korean startups to go
global and of course language matter but
especially it's as an executive level
you need to you know communicate with
other people to understand what they
need and you need to negotiate right so
that's also the one of the biggest
obstacle and also
funding like a lot of starters when I
brought them from Korea to Silicon
Valley even though there's some traction
even though they're you know they're
getting well-known it still was
difficult to get funded because a lot of
theses they want to invest what they're
comfortable about which meaning they
want to invest company within us they
can help and they can take care of and
they they can give you know strategies
and advice but if the company actually
start from the Korea side then a lot of
investors I don't know about Korean
market so it's no thank you please
that's I've experienced a lot with my
Korean startups so if I bring all my
team from Korea I would actually suggest
investor that like we were open to
accept any advice from investor here
that that's why we need those investor
to be a strategic partner because
investment is not just about money it's
about strategy you get all the network
and you get the strategy from investment
investment so that you can scale so so I
would say those kind of things to
investor but you'll be still hard but I
think a lot of Korean startup they focus
on I do this I do this my products this
without telling how they're going to
grow and how they're going to do the
business in the United States so that's
why I put the product fit because and
also the business skill they they only
you know focus on their own stigma as I
said that they don't change the product
they say for example design Korean
product design is much more detail wise
unlike us if you do you guys know a
couple talk if you compare a Kakao Talk
with the whatsapp the design is whole
different what that is so simple
unlike Kakao Talk
pocket talk is basically there's
everything there but if actually they
bring I'll talk to us were they
able to success I don't think so because
the design fit that product it doesn't
really fit for American culture so when
you come to different market your
product has to be changed to for the
people who are actually living in the
area that you are selling and also you
need to know how to porch approach the
people who you're selling that means the
union network that's actually involved
with the investment side because
investor will give you the network
investor will you know guide you to you
know some of the strategic partners that
if you cannot do it they can help you so
but what you need to do is like you need
to be charming to and open-minded to
approach those people and let them know
how much you're passionate so so that
you know they can help you but a lot of
startups they're scared or maybe they're
not comfortable with their language that
they they actually don't even ask and
they just keep building and building in
their garage or they're living around or
and then they keep you know only
chatting with the Korean people but if
you want to scale in this different
country talk to people out there you
know doesn't matter they're different
race doesn't matter where they come from
they're all your customer they're all
your investor you never know so reach
out to people and talk to those people
and listen and and think and whether it
has to be completely changed and you
still need to keep your own values and
combine those you know advice or
listening
this is one statistics that I I got it
when I was researching this is how I
don't want to say bad but bad Korean
startups in terms of respecting
diversity
I don't blame it because we've been
invaded so many times and I sometimes I
had that attitude that it is difficult
for me to completely open and accept a
different culture or accept a different
you know races but I was you know able
to figure out how to be flexible but a
lot of creams they are educated to stick
with one blood we call a honeymoon so
honey honeymoon to Panama joke sorry
that we have to stick with one blood so
that we were able to you know fight all
the people there who are invading right
so it makes sense that we actually have
hard time accepting international
employees or international business
people to actually get close to us
and that is a big big big obstacle for
screen startup to scale I do think so
[Music]
next one is um you know what it is
who is she is one Wonder Woman I want to
talk about my experience as a female
entrepreneur and female career woman I
figure a lot of conferences are actually
about how difficult and what kind of
attitude I should or we women should
have or other people have simply put
being a career female woman
I mean career woman is constant
challenge it's so difficult especially
in Asia
and Korea we we are they are still in
still in male dominant society I was
saying it's changing definitely but when
I was working as especially in tech
world there most of times whenever I
went to meeting I was the only female
investor when youngest and sometimes
they even you know stopped me talking or
they didn't even you know pay attention
to me or didn't even say hi because I'm
a woman
and it was very difficult
honestly it became some sort of personal
attack that is it me that because I
carry you know Miss Korea title or is it
me that I didn't study engineering but I
realized that actually it was not I was
actually being comfortable being who I
am I know what kind of talent I had and
you know I I was partner at my firm
so it actually bothers some of the other
you know people that they had to find a
way to work with female investor and I
do see some of the statistic I
researched that it actually is not just
my personal thing when you look at the
percentage of the female founders in
startups in Korea and where else the
female employees the founders percentage
is 10% but female employee rate is
twenty four percent which means so many
a female career women they don't want to
take in charge to start their own
business or you know start creating a
challenge to be in front of like people
you know to get invested or to to
challenge themselves it's just very
difficult and I have some female
founders in case startup and we've been
gathering together how it is difficult
for us to actually make other investor
to to be serious about our business and
some you know I don't want to generalize
it but most of times I think they
they've faced a challenge and it's
actually not just Korea I have a lot of
female founder group in Silicon Valley
there we share all the difficulties
being an entrepreneur and one of the
biggest thing was actually when we do
the fundraising you're basically begging
it right begging money you're the you're
in the position that you need help that
some mean you know some not very good
investor they take advantage of it that
sometimes it leads to sexual harassment
that I have I happen to actually you
know fight for my friend one time who
asked you know sexual deal to exchange
money it actually is happening still and
and I really think that women we have a
different talent we have better
empathetic skill we have I think a
little bit better than EQ then male
right that it actually helps startups
and actually a company to coordinate and
and grow because for example my company
we have male and you know female and
sometimes we argue and sometimes I like
but we have female like you know
employees
that they can talk to the other employee
you know better that we like we make
sure there are missions that we go for
those mission and we don't get
sidetracked you know and I do think that
when you accept the the difference being
a woman and when you accept a woman's
talent actually it helps the culture
better and every you know aspect of idea
you cover all this idea of you know that
you're missing for the as like logical
male thinking that it will lead to the
special special specialty and also to be
unique
before I end the presentation and my
lecture I think the most important thing
is actually knowing who you are and what
you want actually it all comes from that
the reason I can stand here is because I
always had a dream that I want to be
global I may not be the smartest person
in the world right but I was stick with
my own dream that I keep challenging if
I don't know I just ask and and finding
what I want and achieving one by one and
there are many students here and you
probably struggle what you're going to
do after school or even if you have a
job maybe it doesn't suit you that you
want to explore the business school you
want maybe that's why you're here to
listen my story but listening my story
is helpful but it all should come from
your your advice your thinking first
what do I like what kind of business do
I want to start you know what kind of
team do I want am I able to accept
diversity if I don't what should I do
you know and ask yourself keep asking
yourself then ask other people ask other
people dead goat device to get the
advice and bring the advice to yours and
make a harmony out of it
then I'm pretty sure that one day your
dream will come true thank you so much
Yujin thank you for a really great
heartfelt presentation I appreciate that
so much I want to start out the
questions by asking you what was the
biggest difference between will move
over here what was the biggest
difference but and I'll stand on the
other side you can stay closer to the
middle what was the biggest difference
between working with the accelerator and
being an entrepreneur yourself because
you were working with startups you were
helping them get ahead yeah I mean until
I did the operational side like I said I
had no idea how actually teamwork
matters because when I was just you know
helping entrepreneurs I'm not
I even though I was like you know
hands-on helping I'm not daily involved
right and what when I actually started
my like you know I start up like
sometimes okay for example I I go to a
meeting and fundraise and first for the
first time I fund fund fund raise for
life site because I am Miss Korea or
because I'm female they actually ask
more technology question than extra
crisp I freaked out I freaked out but so
what I did was I came to my head
engineer and asked him to let you know
tutor me so he gave me tutor about
security every week so everything that I
learned from the whole journey of
entrepreneurship is actually I can't do
by myself
I need my team member to help me to sell
and my selling will benefit them so I
have to make sure that they go
in the right direction and focus you
know so that was a that was a real
experience that I learned as an
operational person yeah yeah okay so if
you were to go back and do the
accelerator work again would you do it
different hmm I um I think that I cannot
involve with the company's operational
sight because it's their own team it's
their own family right I can advise them
but I think being our advisor too much
involved with the company's operations
is also really not good because it's
they actually it's their work and yours
are just to help burn and so you have to
let them focus and give them half well
when they need help not involve too much
right because you don't know what's
going on daily right but but I would
actually you know be more friendly
because entrepreneurship is very very
hard
I mean I'm dressing up nicely today but
it's really rare actually I'm like
wearing glasses wearing backpack
going like you know launching view from
all the way for San Francisco I'm
sometimes arguing when my co-founder
yelling him he asked me like you know
it's just a lot of things happening
everyday and if you don't leave yourself
it's like it's it's a big challenge and
it's a big commitment it's really not
easy it's not glamorous actually
everyday but it's really fun when you
have a right team supporting each other
we you know you run for white girls it's
just fascinating so I would actually
relate to entrepreneur when I yeah other
things that Silicon Valley teams can
learn from Korea ah let's see I think
Korean startups or Korean people are
very very fast yeah we we do everything
so fast that you know our economy grew
like you know in 30 years right so maybe
some of the execution side
I think Silicon Valley it's much more
contemplating about one decision you
discuss a lot but sometimes I feel like
is too much yeah
so I would really go to do it yeah yeah
sometimes I'll don't talk just do it so
I got one more question and we'll open
it up before so okay Asia has the
reputation for male domination and for
women having a hard time right were you
surprised when you got the Silicon
Valley that Silicon Valley was not more
open or Yusuf either this is open how
did how did the Silicon Valley situation
for being a woman in a start-up was it a
surprise for you here honestly no okay
because one thing I was surprised is
actually there is much more movement on
female power so I was invited to speak
so many women female heart focus
conferences online Asia but I think in
terms of daily fundraising or daily life
for example like a lot of my friends
female friends here they actually
thinking about quitting their startup or
theirs they're scared scared to start
their business because they don't know
what to do when they give birth they
don't know what to do when when they
start their family and I don't think the
regulations or the government support is
still not there as well here because
like I do like I just talked about with
my friends that she said I need at least
three thousand dollars every month for
one nanny if I want to if you want to
work that's a lot of money you know and
if and you know kids they need you know
attention love and family support so
people question women who give their
support to other things in addition to
their family it's not like a zero-sum
game right but yet for there is this
expectation right right so I mean
Zuckerberg he took like how many months
you know that after the birth but real I
don't think that it's common actually
so also yeah I would actually want like
you know gentlemen's here to understand
how difficult it is sometimes to be a
woman to fear oldest challenge you know
and it's not towards us us we care about
our family we care about future and
children you know is our future right
it's like a song so so definitely we
like biking on mail you know men should
care about women's welfare as well you
know for their own family
we should hover over you yeah I got it
okay thanks let's open before the
questions go ahead you do these on you
experience any advice that you can give
on how to effectively sell a foreign
market the surveillance to Silicon
Valley investors I think it's not just
Silicon Valley investor but I would say
when I was teaching the pitch a lot of
entrepreneurs there's so much going on
right on and with your you know Prague
or even your mission so if I would give
an advice that make a very lean and
simple presentation and very clear about
what you're building and you know what
you're why you're doing this and what's
the difference with your company than
other competitors out there it was a
business model you know and how much
attraction urines like it's very clear
about what you're selling to investor
then you get the tension that's what I
actually experience and I whenever I
taught my you know Korean startups they
were never educated to summarize or make
it simple that I think it was difficult
for him to get attention but once I
actually taught them every time I taught
them I was so surprised by how much
investor who ignored that portfolio
actually look at them so I would
actually
I encourage you to make a very you know
logical and very simple work flow of
their presentation and yeah thank you
thank culture yeah going back your
accelerator and need to be the day I'm
gonna just be Alan I get a lot of
classmates who are from Korea okay so I
have a lot of experience with this great
friends of mine I mean these guys are
exceptionally bright people what I
realized from them like you said earlier
is there is a high stigma failure
request and another thing that they
brought my attention is you know those
corporations you mentioned LG Samsung
and they revenue is pretty close to 50%
of the Korean achievement and they
totally that pretty close to 700 people
applied for every position in these
audiences what they only what the stigma
of failure prevents people even very
bright people who come to Stanford to
venture into entrepreneurial opportunity
consequently also what happens is the
employees are not too open to working in
our business so what happens is you as
an entrepreneur don't find resources
right resources because those resources
Wow yeah yes because well as as an
incubator or as an accelerator
what is that you can do to fight this
stigma that exists in the Korean society
I know it's these huge but as an
incubator what can you so I actually
it's a really good comment because I was
thinking of putting that comment here
because a lot of actually startups in
Korea when they start their companies
one of the challenge was actually
getting good engineers actually like
engineers they are just so expensive and
so the good engineers they know they're
good that they
they play games it's like dating and I
don't think it's just one person or one
companies like you know challenge it has
to come up from the I think government
level of solving problems like policies
like so for example when government
Korean government they put lots of money
in the you know ecosystem of startup
surprisingly because of that money we
attract so many good people who studied
US or other countries they come back to
Korea start their own company because
they knew that they can get money from
government or accelerator or VC easily
so but then as I mentioned the after
series aid there is a missing space for
funding or growth or acquisition so I
would say the government should have
some sort of lower leg relation for big
companies like Nhan or Kakao like you
know or Samsung to acquire companies
maybe a little bit you reduce the tax or
because I remember one time NHIN Naver
which is the it's like a Google in Korea
they said they're not going to acquire
any companies when I was running the
accelerator or they're not going to
invest any cream startled and I was like
are you serious
why and then they said because of Korean
you know green public they're going to
you know target us because we're just
going to eat up a small company and also
the government is not you know helping
anything
so I I do think that it has to come up
with like the very high level and
changing maybe tax for those companies
to to to reduce the regulation to you
know have a very good circulation with
startup to big company and you the good
engine you come out to startup like you
know then it may solve the problem
that's my personal opinion
yeah actually do you mind if I come in a
little bit all because this is an area
that
things really critical the exit is so
important and one reason you know what
you really want Korean companies buying
up start-up companies unless they really
know how to use the idea I mean because
if they buy you to keep you out of the
market that's not the good thing right
but on the other hand it's really being
able to get the benefits of the
partnership in the fresh blood and the
fresh idea from the startup and I think
that's kind of the next stage and
entrepreneurship going international
we've had the stage where people are
creating as you see it's still not
enough follow-on funding right but to
get that follow-on funding you have to
have a goal right it has to lead to
something right yeah that's just a big
challenge and I don't know how long you
were going to take but has to be
government VC all the ecosystem grow
together and keep keep you know
investing time and money in in you know
first startup industry then maybe slowly
change and what was it like going from
the media business having your own TV
show and suddenly working in you know an
accelerator what a different world I
mean was it a culture shop ah not a
culture shock but it was difficult
obviously because I was on the spotlight
but when I started accelerator literally
my startups are the one there who have
to get the spotlight so I have to be the
woman they will make them you know shine
I struggle in the beginning but I was
happy actually you know media like you
know it's glamorous outside but it's
like I always have to pay attention to
my look and the people sometimes judge
me actually judge me a lot about what I
look like you know outside only but when
I went to they actually startup industry
you know especially early stage there
are so many people who are passionate
about what they're building and dream it
was just like me
that I I was able to relate to them you
so I was able to quickly adapt to the
cart dragon yeah okay are you going to
take live site to Korea I not right away
for because of all the regulations
actually that's the thing
Korean government also had to solve I
think they're trying to realize that the
regulations for example active they're
going to you know demolish the ActiveX
you know like if you are using Mac you
can't open some of the Korean internet
because they still run with the ActiveX
you know with the Explorer that some of
them if you don't have a window that you
can't open the websites and stuff but I
think new government is now realizing
that oldest you know technology
regulation can prohibit other business
to come to you know in Korea that that
may be helped but is it mostly that kind
of technology regulation or is that more
things like privacy and what kind of I
really and everything begun like I think
it's a culture of component as well that
like I said Korean green you know the
reason I say yes Korean families are big
and they're close
right I mean you have an extended family
yeah
and I would think that there would be
some sort of a tiered approach where the
people in the real center get access to
anything and you know kind of a polar
system yeah but that's not the issue
actually the cultural component that I
was talking about is more about
regulation because we're dealing with
the security right and every country has
a different career bar and privacy rules
that we do think that Korean in China
markets is challenging still but we are
actually already talking with the
Japanese government in in your nation
government which actually they've been
through the natural disaster that they
want caught up like us so but actually
Samsung they approached us
and some of the Korean government do
keep an eye on me okay yes other
questions I have a question
No so if you don't have a mechanism for
for entrepreneurial companies in Korea
saying that you're you don't how did the
companies innovate and that seems to be
the way that we do it here big companies
don't have to have a really hard time
innovating and they buy smaller
companies and that becomes their
innovation edge if you don't have this
in Korea what cash how do people how did
a large company renovating this is kind
of sad to talk I mean they do have you
know Samsung and they have great people
have you know they have innovation team
right but sadly here they acquire those
innovative team in the accepted
innovation but a lot of companies like
uber like Santa Maria LG they actually
don't want to spend money to acquire the
idea so they still it they copy and then
build their own and they so a lot of
startups they have to be careful that
big company they don't copy because they
have better engineering team they're
better resource right so but I do think
things are starting to change
yes yeah I mean I'm seeing groups like
the Innovation Center Samsung
innovations that are down in Santa Clara
that are much more outward and openly
looking they've gotten to the stage
where they know they need to partner
with outside but it's really hard to
convince all the people back home and so
I think that you're seeing this yeah
yeah I definitely I mean Samsung they
want to build something like us so they
they found me they approached me so and
they have an innovation team and they
have venture team keep looking I on new
technology new startups but it is
actually limited and it's it's it's a
little bit hard for those big company to
acquire those teaming operate it inside
of the hierarchy based
company so yeah so one of the things
that I've heard that's been going on in
Korea for the last four or five years is
that young people the cause it's so hard
to get a job are really getting kind of
depressed and just feel like the system
has passed and by our startup is a good
way for even to really get into
absolutely I think the 2013 the reason
government they created the Future
Department and all the start ecosystem
movement actually was started from
saving all those young unemployed people
because it the only way they can get job
is working for Samsung working for LG
we're going to you know medical school
or lawyer right but so the government
thought that if they create job which
they create business then they can save
all this unemployment so that's why they
put a lot of you know budget on the star
of ecosystem and I think it helped
like literally Korea is now changing I
see the movement I see the bright future
but it takes time like it's a culture of
movements of government and all this
team play actually with so we had we've
just had a change of government in Korea
right the previous president has been
impeached and is now on trial and just
last week there was an election do you
think the new Korean president is going
to basically keep the same sort of
approach to entrepreneurship or if you
already see new policies honestly I
cannot answer correctly I know that it's
I do so I chatted with partner a
sparklab which became number one
accelerate in Korea they're still
running very well and they said that I
was worried about after the the the form
of government
it's the scar ecosystem supporting will
be gone but actually he said that
they're passing the accelerator law so
that accelerate can have a you know
claim they're fun even the fun size is
small you know all those like movement
is still keep going that I don't
at that there's a bright future for
Korean star of ecosystem and green
market is still not too small actually
and and as long as we keep you know
changing and challenging and keep
working on I guess yeah okay so what
about startup companies here Silicon
Valley startups so if you look back in
Asia
you've got China which is huge you've
got India which is huge you've got
Indonesia which is actually a lot bigger
than people realize what's special about
Korea what would be good what would be a
good reason for a company to go to Korea
so Korea is a number one fastest mobile
penetration market and Korean people are
so tech savvy that if you want to test
your product go to Korea especially
consumer base products go to Korea
whether they like it or not and Korea is
a small country but we are you know open
I mean we're we're close minded but
somehow we're you know contract ly like
we're open to like accept some of the
American culture and create their own in
their own country it's like you know a
lot of cafes if you don't get them like
you're the big tall building none all so
it's like it's kind of like American but
still career I know a little bit like
yeah yeah I got you you're right yeah
so it's a good way to test encrypt like
you know your market I mean your
business in Korea and Korean people I do
I'm very proud of and they're they're
very smart
so yeah I do think you know yeah so I
guess my last question to you then is
really when you started out with the
Miss Korea pageant and all of this you
wanted to tell the world about Korea
right you let people know about Korea
how has that vision changed oh of course
I I'm still Korean and I grew up with
military family I
grew up in dmz area looking at North
Korean all the time even now and I'm a
very I think Patriot person so even
though I love America I I see the
potentials and I love the diversity but
I do you know I do think that Korea is a
small country but we have Samsung and we
have LG it's like you know it's a tiny
country but people know what we are
famous for and I hope I am one of a
value that people when they meet me they
know about and they learn about Korea a
little bit more good and bad so maybe it
won't be too long for people no doubt
LifeSite yes thank you so much enjoy
this was great today
[Applause]